Enosh
When people gradually started to learn that I was researching Jewish music
A lot of people said: 'Oh, you must speak to Rudi Leavor.'
When I first met Rudi, which was at the Bradford synagogue,
I asked him what his story was, as it were.
He talked about his youth, and then the Nazi occupation, etc.
And how he'd come to England. And he talked a little bit about
how he'd been a singer in the synagogue, most of his life,
eventually became the Kantor the Bradford synagogue.
He played violin, as a child,
but had never had any kind of formal theoretical,
university level type of education in music.
In fact, he was a dentist, very good dentist, I believe.
But he kept that music going. And then in the nine- in the 70s,
He composed Enosh.
Not- I don't know if it was exactly out of the blue,
but it seems to be out of the blue.
He told me about this in a very matter of fact, way.
'Oh, yeah. And then in the 70s I,'
'I composed this opera' as he called it.
Not quite accurate, but that doesn't matter.
I composed his opera called Enosh.
I said: 'Oh yeah, what's that?'
And he said: 'Oh it's a it's a thing for chorus and full orchestra solos.
[inaudible]
Rudy was very musically knowledgeable,
from a sort of very advanced amateur level.
He knew his opera very well.
He was an admirer of Bach, and Mozart, Beethoven,
you know the sorts of classic-
My father played the piano, Chopin, Schubert, Beethoven,
and my mother sang
As a child or his father had some LPs, I think,
that they listened to, I think one of them was
the Berlioz L’enfance du Christ,
which remained a very dear piece to him throughout his life
and was performed in the same concept as-
well an extract from it was was performed in same concert as Enosh.
And so, he was steeped in a sort of Western classical music tradition,
as well as a synagogue music tradition,
some of which is very similar to that western classical tradition,
but some of it some of which is not.
And it's very almost Islamic in nature, or Arabic, certainly, in its influences.
And so what I think he was trying to achieve was to meld
his knowledge of classical music with that synagogue tradition.
Enosh
It's like an oratoria, really.
Rudi, didn't just leave the tunes as they were.
He sort of intervened musically, he changed aspects of some of the
what we might call hymns, in the synagogue.
The classic one is Enosh 'Mankind'
which is sung on Yom Kippur. It's very serious.
It's sort of the end of a long process of
praying and singing towards the end of a fast.
It's very well known in the Jewish world.
But he changed aspects of harmony,
sort of played around with the rhythm a little bit.
You'll hear it start and you'll think 'Oh, yes that's Enosh.'
And then you'll hear something a bit different.
And you'll think 'Oh, that's not quite what I remember.'
And it makes you think more about the music
rather than just hearing a familiar tune.
What he was trying to do is to is to sort of feed into a tradition,
or two traditions, the Jewish and the Western classical music.
But to disrupt it a little bit and draw our attention to certain things.
And the soloists music is in a much more modern idiom.
It's beautifully written actually.
The story is of the Jewish people, essentially.
It starts with the people of Israel, being happy
to have arrived in the Promised Land.
And then it becomes gradually more serious
as they're overtaken by various events throughout history.
Whilst it's never upfront, explicitly expressed,
you can identify particular historical things,
and eventually coming to the Holocaust.
And there's a moment where there's obvious references to Hitler
without naming him and to the horrors that
were perpetrated upon the Jewish people.
And then after that, there is a short epilogue, I guess
whereby there is a sort of sign of hope for the future,
I would say a qualified hope, not a
not an a sort of an ecstatic, uncontrolled hope.
But there is a sort of root space for reflection and optimism.
He left Germany quite early on in his childhood.
And he left before the worst of the atrocities otherwise,
one might assume, sadly, that he wouldn't have survived.
So thank God, he did leave.
So he never spoke to me about that individually,
but I knew the history, more or less.
We went by train, ship, train, and then train.
I liked travelling, the excitement,
I think, whilst again, he never articulated it precisely.
I think that that was quite a powerful
personal, I wouldn't say reconciliation with,
but engagement with an expression of that trauma that survivors suffer.
I think certainly the power of the music that he wrote,
that comes from somewhere.
I think he was working through a number
of historical, emotional aspects
From Hamburg to Bremer Hafen we had the compartment to ourselves.
Then the customs officer came around,
he asked my father to go to another compartment.
We stopped at a station. When we set off I said:
'Where's daddy?'
My mother was just as frightened. But she said: 'He'll be along.'
They had asked him questions and body searched him.
He did talk about his, his escape,
for want of a better word, the music and the narrative in the text
works through some of that idea of escape,
and finding a better life somewhere.
And then, the risk of it all happening again,
and eventual partial catharsis.
So there was a tender to take us on the ship to the quay side.
We went to the station. It seemed very dark.
It was November. So it got dark early.
It was raining, there were gas lights,
and the train puffed a lot of steam.
That was our entry to England.
And the new and better life.
One could tell when he felt something very deeply.
He's very sincere man. A very gentle man.
I would say. One of my main impulses behind doing it was
Yes, there's a self interest in terms of the research
and the potential academic outcomes and things like that.
But actually, the most important thing for me was to do it,
to get it done for Rudi.
Because he kept saying to me, I'm on a limited timescale here.
He knew that he wouldn't be surviving another 20 years or something
and that it needed to be done there and then.
And so, within the kind of confines of what I could do,
I wanted to do it for him primarily.